في عام
1984 حذر علماء جيولوجيون من وقوع كارثه
كبرى في امريكا الجنوبيه حدث مهول يهدد
سكان كولومبيا كان هذا الحدث ثاني اعنف
كارثه بركانيه خلال القرن العشرين عندما
ثار بركان نيفادو ديل رويز متسببا بماساه
تاريخيه اودت بحياه اكثر من 24 الف شخص
فما قصتها
في اواخر العام
1984 وقعت ثلاثه زلازل على بعد ثلاثين
كيلومترا من قمه نيفادو ديل رويز التي تعد
اعلى القمم البركانيه في جمهوريه كولومبيا
ما عزز من النشاط البركاني بالمنطقه
فتشكلت فوهه بركان جديده داخل الحفره
الرئيسيه
في مارس من العام
1985 حذر عالم زلازل زارا المنطقه من حدوث
انفجار بركاني كبير خصوصا مع استمرار
الهزات الزلزاليه في محيط الجبل ما ادى
الى اعلان حاله الطوارئ في شهر سبتمبر من
العام نفسه في 13 من نوفمبر وفي الساعه
الثالثه مساء كانت الشراره الاولى للكارثه
الكبرى حيث ثار بركان نيفادو ديل رويس لكن
السلطات لم تتحرك نحو الشروع في الاخلاء
لان الجبل هدا بعد فتره وجيزه في الساعه
التاسعه مساء ثار البركان مره اخرى فاهتزت
المباني اسفل الجبل وتصاعدت الادخنه التي
بعثت منها رائحه الكبريت انعدمت الرؤيه
بشكل مفاجئ وبدات الامطار الغزيره بالهطول
كما توهجت السحب في السماء كما لو كانت
مصابيح في وسط الظلام
تسببت حراره الحمم المنبعثه في ذوبان 16%
من جليد قمه نيفادو ديل رويز وهو ما كان
كافيا لاطلاق ثلاثه واربعين مليون طن من
المياه اندمجت في طريقها مع القنوات
النهريه حامله معها الرماد والرواسب
والصخور والاشجار اتجهت جميعها نحو مدن
ارميرو وتشينشينا والقرى المحيطه بها كان
من المستحيل على اي شخص عبور الطين لين
دون ان يغوص فيه كما لم تكن حركه فرق
الانقاذ ومعداتها ممكنه داخل الوحل فتعذر
انقاذ الكثير من الاشخاص المحاصرين في
الساعه الحاديه عشره والنصف مساء وصلت
المياه لمدينه ارميرو ودفنتها بعمق يصل
لخمسه امتار من السطح خلال الساعتين
التاليتين تم دفن 85% من المدينه تحت
الطين في غضون اربع ساعات غطت الفيضانات
والانهيارات الارضيه مس واسعه على بعد 60
ميلا عن قمه البركان ما اسفر عن مقتل اكثر
من 23 الف شخص واصابه اكثر من خمسه الاف
شخص وتدمير اكثر من خمسه الاف منزل فيما
كانت مدينه ارميرو الاكثر تضررا حيث مات
ثلاثه ارباع سكانها البالغ عددهم
28,700 نسمه على الجانب الغربي من البركان
دفن الوحل احياء المنخفضه وقدر المسؤولون
ان الف شخصا ماتوا هناك
قدر عدد الضحايا باكثر من عشرين الفا كان
الالاف منهم قد لقوا حتفهم خلال الساعات
24 التاليه بسبب تراجع خدمات الرعايه
الصحيه من بين الضحايا برز اسمشيز الفتاه
التي لم تتجاوز الثالثه عشر من عمرها بعد
صوره التقطت لها ونصف جسدها عالق تحت
الانقاض فيما لمعت عيناها الحمراوان لكن
صوره نشرت في الكثير من الصحف حول العالم
واعتبرت صوره العام لسنه
1986 حيث عبرت عن تقاعس السلطات عن اتخاذ
الاجراءات الصحيحه لمواجهه خطر الكوارث
كما باتت الفتاه رمزا للشجاعه في الثقافه
الكولومبيه
اليوم وبعد اكثر من 37 عاما على الكارثه
الكبرى لا يزال بركان نيفادو ديل رويز
يمثل تهديدا خطيرا لما يصل الى نصف مليون
شخص في المدن والبلدات والقرى المجاوره
[موسيقى]